Okay, so I've gone ahead and pulled up a meme of myself.
And let's analyze the way this text is drawn.
Memes tend to use white text that is outlined in black.
This makes it easy to read the text no matter what background it's over.
So in this case, the like here is on top of a light background, but
we can read it really easily because of the black outline.
And then down here, over my dark shirt because the letters have
white fills inside they're easily legible there too.
So this is a nice strategy for making sure that text is always legible.
The way this is accomplished is with a mix of fill and stroke text.
To the scripts I've added this method, stroke text.
Which is going to draw the string hello udacity.
And it's going to put it at the point 50, 10.
Now, note here that this 50 is going to be,
in the case of this text, the lower left-hand corner of the text.
So, if this were 0,
0 we wouldn't be able to see the text because the lower left-hand corner
would be at zero and the rest of the text wouldn't be above the page.
So that's just something to know.
Let's go ahead and see what happens when we call this method.
Come over here and hit Refresh.
And we can see that we now have a hello udacity written in
the same green color that we set earlier drawn at the position 50, 10.
This string here could be any string and we can use JavaScript to set it.
We could also use fillText instead.
I'll go ahead and save that.
Now we've got fillText.
I'll come over here and hit refresh, and
we've got hello udacity written in the same blue color that we set here.
In addition to letting us decide what strings to draw on the page and
where to draw them, the Canvas 2D context allows us to set a lot of
other options, like for instance, font size, font style, and line width.
Check the instructor notes for more information.